ket Canada GG gorgeous and we are here
on my fashion magazine cover shoot
[Music]
this shoot is kind of punk straight but
still very very chic I'm wearing this
leather top it would have never picked
out for myself but I'm loving it
GG strikes some serous poses on the
streets of LA for her first major cover
shoot in his new dance today being on
the cover of fashion magazine was
probably one of the most exciting things
I could have heard I remember growing up
and buying fashion magazine I mean I
would go through all the different looks
and the trends it's an honor the theme
of the issue is boundary breakers and
Gigi's definitely represents in 2008
before she transitioned the world met
Gregory gorgeous famous for his unique
voice in makeup tutorials Gregory became
a bonafide YouTube superstar with
millions of fans if your parents don't
get you if your friends think you're
weird I love you and I want you to be
exactly who you want you to be earlier
this year Gigi showed us everything with
her raw revealing and yes boundary
breaking documentary that premiered at
the Sundance Film Festival
I've always broken boundaries and pushed
the limits in my own life and in the
lives of others my loved ones my friends
I always encourage people to just live
authentically and unapologetically and I
think you know it's a perfect fit and it
can be here
the Montreal born star now calls
California home but Canada will always
be in her heart being on the cover of a
Canadian magazine is just a dream come
true I mean my father is so excited
about this shoot he's one of the first
people I told it's gonna be crazy I'm
gonna have to make a special trip home
to see myself and all the newsstands